right now
there are 1500 active volcanoes
on earth just one of those volcanoes
could do
catastrophic damage but at midnight
tonight
every volcano on the planet is erupting
you might want to cancel any plants you
have
how much damage are we talking about
here
what would life be like for the
survivors
and what do you mean it gets even worse
than lava
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if a volcanic apocalypse happened
tomorrow
brace yourself this may just be the
worst weather forecast you're ever going
to hear
every volcano on earth active or dormant
on land or under the sea is ready
to blow the lid off this place you can
expect to see
plumes of ash lava bombs and jet spurts
on
every single continent and in every
single ocean
but i know what you're thinking you can
take the heat right
well take a seat there sparky it's gonna
get a whole lot worse if
every volcano on earth erupted at once
it would set off some high magnitude
earthquakes
this is because so many volcanoes are
located near the shifting tectonic
plates of the earth and
while the lava and earthquakes would
certainly do some major damage
one of the biggest blows we're going to
face is the nasty
gases that spew out of volcanoes
clouds of gas smoke and ash can travel
in almost liquid-like motions to
anywhere in the world
they could smother the earth in a matter
of minutes
but let's say for a second you managed
to survive the initial explosions
well i've got two very upsetting words
for you
volcanic ash the volcanic ash
would black out the skies blocking any
sunlight in the process
this would cause the temperature on
earth to plummet
without the sun the earth's surface
temperature
would plunge to zero degrees after the
first week
and then to minus 66 degrees by the end
of the first year
on the bright side it's not an inferno
of death anymore
to make matters worse no sunlight means
no plants which means no food for
animals most animal species would go
extinct
as the loss of plants would set off a
mass extinction
due to its impact on the food chain and
don't hold your breath for the
stragglers you can expect
acid rain to take care of them this is
because of those volcanic gases we
mentioned earlier
hydrochloric acid hydrogen fluoride
hydrogen sulfide
and sulfur dioxide would condense in the
atmosphere
and they would fall to the earth as rain
this would then contaminate any fresh
water supply we had left
[Music]
but what if we had some fighters still
kicking
what would life be like for those living
in the aftermath
well the economy isn't going to do you
any favors
the volcanic destruction would cause a
complete economic collapse
every business and bank would shut down
you'd lose access to credit and become
instantly unemployed
unless you count being a wasteland
survivor as your new job
this is peter day 124 coming to you live
from
inside my underground bunker you know
since the apocalypse
people lost everything not me i had a
plan
you know even before the economy
literally burnt to the ground
i invested in gold owning gold can
act as a hedge against inflation
deflation and
in this case the apocalypse it's
literally the gold standard for value
and
can provide financial coverage in these
uncertain times
you should head on over to the sponsor
of this video jmbullion.com
jm bullion is a discreet easy to use
physical precious metals retailer with
over 4 billion in revenue
and over 2 million orders shipped jm
bullion is one of the largest most
respected online retailers of physical
gold and silver products in the world
since using jmbullion.com life down here
has been golden
get it because it's gold
there's not a lot of people down here to
talk to
it would be full-blown post-apocalyptica
out there
searching the ash-covered world for
aquifers containing fresh water
venturing out into the wasteland for
supplies and
living in heated underground bunkers
now while it is very possible that
volcanoes
could set each other off by being in
close proximity
the chances of every volcano on earth
exploding at once is highly unlikely
but it does make us think about how
quickly things can go south
[Music]
what if we could prepare for something
like this
what if we built the world's deepest
bunker
well that's a story for another
what if